sie alle sind auf und davon
diener und tablet schmid mit ihren
kindern im iran und rohan
sie leben nun in australien der
ehemalige tagesschau moderator erkennt
er ist in den kongo ausgewandert monika
und trete maggioni mit den töchtern jara
und selina ihre neue heimat ist das
wüstenemirat dubai sandra und dann
können gallo
die beiden haben eine farm in kanada
gekauft der ispo nett und claudio
candrian sie bauen ihr eigenes haus auf
der karibik insel margarita
[Musik]
ein einziger wintermorgen in kanada bei
sandra und danken gano seit über drei
monaten leben sie ihren traum von der
eigenen farm das leben in der schweiz
und die arbeit auf einem golfplatz sieht
nur mehr vage erinnerungen hier in
kanada dreht sich alles um die
mutterkuhhaltung oder das kleine kalb
das in der letzten folge auf die welt
gekommen ist wird von duncan ganz
speziell umsorgt bevor es zur mutter
darf offiziell kanadische oder jährige
[Musik]
also fortschritten ist vom zeigt dass
keine identifizieren
gegenüber dem motto wer zu wem du bist
aber kräftig
[Applaus]
das versuchen tierschützer weiß gar
nicht ob wir das kriegsschiff das so
wendet wie heute könnt ihr ganz früher
jetzt bist du schon fertig als lange die
mama
die mama des kalbs spürt gleich ihrem
mutterinstinkt und vertreibt alle
anderen kälbchen
nein
[Musik]
die herde von sandra und danken ist
mittlerweile auf 100 40 kühe und über
ein dutzend kälbchen angewachsen und um
ein kalb seiner herde macht sich duncan
große sorgen
es will einfach nicht trinken
apathisch liegt es da
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wird es wieder auf die beine kommen in
der letzten folge ist familie maggioni
in dubai endlich in ihr neues haus in
der greenfield community gezogen und die
hat sogar einen künstlichen see und das
mitten in der wüste
nachdem die familie des emirates piloten
reto maggioni über drei monate in einem
hotel appartement leben musste ist sie
glücklich ihre eigenen vier wände zu
haben seit über sechs monaten leben die
maronis mission beiden töchtern zerlina
und chiara nun bereits in der wüste und
gewöhnen sich langsam an ihre neue
heimat
im erdgeschoss in der küche kochen
monika und reto zusammen alles friedlich
und harmonisch hatten die beiden
eigentlich schon einmal streiten dubai
[Musik]
somit trägt geschichte schweiz auf das
eigentlich mehr oder wenige pixel
ausarbeitungen 15 gleicht und fdp haben
bis jetzt gemacht wird desto weniger
abwenden
das ist eingesperrt
die sich in dubai einfach so dass du
fragst ob sie dadurch sogar noch unter
heißt er antwortete wie das geld und den
sektor aus gesteuerten ja machen nicht
abonniert dann bitte ich sage den
hautnah das geld nicht mit bauen und
einen moment überlegt die jäger und
plötzlich heißt er gut machen
[Musik]
verschwinde zähler
und sie stiegen funke mittal group
kommen
[Musik]
und hier in venezuela haben claudio
candrian und theres projekt ihr neues
zuhause
heute haben sie allen grund zufrieden zu
sein der ehemalige er habe lokführer und
die einstige postangestellte fahren zur
baustelle ihres traumhauses
[Musik]
endlich wird gebaut am neuen traum der
beiden
[Musik]
nach den wochenlangen scherereien welche
die beiden mit den kauf ihres
grundstückes hatten läuft nun alles rund
freund pepe ist mittlerweile zum
vorarbeiter geworden
doch damit es so gut läuft dafür mussten
claudia und theres wie hier üblich
ordentlich nachhelfen hätte schmerzt
wenn man ein architekt hat dieses messen
absegnen
und der hätte für das die hohle hand
gemacht drittens 5 millionen tierfoto
gemein und im fernseher ein stetiger den
kauf die architekten der jeder 1,5
millionen wähler und endlich fertig und
mit einer powerplay war dies nie wieder
aber das ist knapp fünf millionen
bolivar rund 1500 franken mussten sie
bezahlen damit niemand ihnen in die
quere kommt wer hätte das gedacht nach
all dem ärger den die beiden in
venezuela hatten konnte nun alles gut
auf der trauminsel
inzwischen haben claudia und theresien
ihrem provisorischen zuhause nachwuchs
bekommen
[Musik]
dann kann das
die große show im und daher zum reserven
und ist im moment nicht
vor ihrem jahr oder gar nichts das ist
alle bauten und ärger denn immer zweimal
slammer krieg
[Musik]
mit der folge nie mehr hängen auch
hansjörg enz im kongo ist glücklich
heute allerdings ein bisschen im stress
denn seine frau anita kommt im
nachbarland burundi an
[Musik]
sein fahrer besser gibt vollgas
seit drei monaten arbeitet hansjörg enz
als entwicklungshelfer in kongo und seit
drei monaten ist er von seiner frau
anita getrennt da will er nicht zu spät
kommen
kurz bevor die grenze schließen schaffen
sie es nach bochum die so lange hält und
sie möchten und so genießt hansjörg enz
am flughafen das wiedersehen mit seiner
frau anita ganz privat
am nächsten morgen
[Musik]
hansjörg enz ist endlich wieder mit
seiner frau anita zusammen
gemeinsam fahren sie die fünf stunden in
den kongo holen die stadt bukavu zurück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hansjörg enz kann es kaum erwarten anita
sein neues haus zu zeigen da einfach mal
das küchen teil auch anita ist vom neuen
zuhause ihres mannes begeistert
[Musik]
celani aufruf des wunders neueste handy
alice springs australien
hier lebt familie schmid seit einem
halben jahr in ihrem haus
touristenführer kevin schmid hat ferien
genommen
heute abend weder amira den richtigen
umgang mit den giftigen tieren in
australien beibringen wc oder ich wurde
bewusst und unter betten
welt vorderhand dann wenn ich dafür zwei
tage im bett rabin und die große cdu sie
transportiert und hornig müsse die
mikrofone gefangen hält sie mit
baseballschläger stadt denn genauso 81
[Musik]
es ist eine der letzten abende hier
denn kate & diener haben vor kurzem die
kündigung bekommen
der besitzer will selber wieder in sein
haus erneut müssen die schmidts nach
einer bleibe suchen
sie stiegen mit davon gekommen
[Musik]
in kanada ist das kalb von duncan gar
immer noch krank und es wie immer noch
nicht trinken
[Musik]
letzte hoffnung eine antibiotika sprit
duncan kommt an seine grenzen
[Musik]
a
ich weiß nicht ob es vom sterben schon
ob es zum schlafen ist zu wenige
verrückt um das gut können
vorteil das 50
sandra gano fährt heute weg in die stadt
duncan sorgen und ängste beschäftigen
auch sie
[Musik]
euro
stress hätten zudem 12 uhr gemacht
nach den scl tigers
das weltall studieren muss die sache
eine marionette
sondern einfach schlechter machen als
mir der arsch tastaturen
sandra wird alle zehn tage die zwei
stunden ins benachbarte sind rohs und
für sich und danken einzukaufen
das budget für den einkauf es knapp
kanada ist teurer als die beiden
erwartet haben
[Musik]
verlag es möglich schon meistens und
drüber nach was diese sind vergleichbar
mit der schweiz
was man bewusst sei dass gibt es auch
europäer sehen
[Musik]
für das fleisch fisch fleisch günstig
und kreise stören
[Musik]
alle ihre ersparnisse weit über eine
halbe million franken haben sie in ihren
traum gestellt es sind bitte hier
pressebox maschine einiges dritter wurde
danken sind traktor über 42.000
webseiten von 20 musikfans dauer alles
zusammen 50 mehr als planer wenn man das
natürlich schon riesig
es langt alles noch bis jetzt
die kälber und die herde sind das
kapital von sandra und danken
da darf nichts schriftlich vom
wohlergehen der tiere hängt ihre ganze
zukunft ab
die halt momentan stand er ruft rechts
wird alles richtig machen
[Applaus]
von oskar beck spielt wenn ich irgendwie
auch verhindert dass soll es kommt nicht
sterben
da mach ich alles
[Musik]
10.000 kilometer luftlinie entfernt in
dubai bei familie macho alle genießen
den freien tag von engels pilot ried
heute fahren sonys wie viele
einheimische aus der hektik dubais für
ein picknick in die weite der wüste
sport
trotzdem steht gewählt
[Musik]
sport auto
reto maroni hat sich anfänglich sorgen
gemacht wie die beiden töchter sich in
ihrer neuen heimat ein leben
[Musik]
und ja und da man im ausweis für
familien wieder zurück als sie endlich
kritik stand
aber wenn es gefühlt oder mache
nachgefragt hätte ich einfach das ist
die frau zum beispiel hier
denn ist ganz klar dass technik frau die
ich spüre dass ein stück vor
das datum war es das teil nicht vor
gefragt
ja genau
bisher wird familie mazzoni in der wüste
glücklich werden
inzwischen laufen in venezuela auf der
karibik insel margarita die bauarbeiten
am kaum haus von claudio ots auf
hochtouren nach den wochenlangen
problemen mit landkauf und
bauverzögerungen können die beiden nun
ein bisschen aufatmen
vorarbeiter ppg staunt über das große
schlafzimmer der beiden schweizer haben
[Musik]
hasta mañana
da
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber dann trübt doch ein ereignis die
stimmung der kleinen weißen katze geht
es immer schlechter
claudio hat sich gegen tores
durchgesetzt
die katze soll jetzt zum tierarzt
kann der kleinen katze noch geholfen
werden in afrika im kongo wohnen heute
hansjörg und anita enz ganz große tiere
besuchen
sie fahren in ein gorilla bar helfen
wird ihnen dabei ein anderer schweizer
der hotelbesitzer karl schuler der seit
über 20 jahren im kongo lebt er hat
dieses reservat frühjahr selbst gemachte
gut bewacht geht es in den dschungel
carlos traut den fahrkünsten von bea dem
fahrer von hansjörg enz nicht wirklich
wie sich zeigt zu recht
der bubi aber kaufen
der chef persönlich muss ans steuer
versuch ertappt
ein schönes hoch die letzten
instruktionen für hansjörg und anita
beobachten
es ist wirklich das auch linie angriff
macht zum beispiel und zeige dass er
eine geschichte her und einmalig schön
ruhig geblieben war
also quasi problem rund 200 gorillas
leben in diesem teil des reservats und
werden von 150 wächtern beschützt
tief im dschungel des kongo treffen
hansjörg und anita schließlich auf einen
gorilla familie
sie lässt sich nicht stören obwohl
unsere auswanderer nur wenige meter von
ihnen entfernt sind
[Musik]
die
diese
[Musik]
theoretisch steht heute der große krieg
waren schon geschützt werden und dann zu
schauen und wir versuchen das auch mit
dem städtischen bis zum col de portet
dass einige wir sind hier und das ist
das was die studieren was mir dass
menschen beschäftigen
[Musik]
in alice springs im herzen von
australien ist mittlerweile viel
passiert denn schmid haben ein neues
haus aus dem alten mussten sie ausziehen
mit der unterstützung von verwandten
konnten sie dieses haus kaufen für
gerade mal 400 tausend franken
denn der vorbesitzer ging pleite und
musste günstig verkaufen
[Musik]
man kann aber steigen auch das zweite
wohnzimmer
mit der barren baute man so noch gar
nicht was man mit dem machen er hat aber
auch sehr gut verständlich und
australische verhältnis das haus verließ
der kredit fürs punkt bei seiner liegt
also einfach schlichtweg für immer ein
haus in dass du mich nur fertig aussieht
das weiß fast immer vom kuchen sind
neben rincon sich gesagt
der reinverlust angeschafft also er hat
sich trotz dieses wohnzimmer das
kinderzimmer nicht im schlaf
dann sei sie clean stube was bekommen
sie stolz photokina für sie ist größte 1
kostet zum innenhafen login wollte und
das riesenfest immer es ist ein
richtiger dort im vergleich zu vorher
was gut ist für ihn und hundt
natürlich so viel mitgemacht als im auto
überhaupt haben wir natürlich an als
auch in zukunft wird das war schien die
hausdame gelogen haben wir speziell
endgültiges zuhause gefunden
in kanada liegt danken garros kalb immer
noch apathisch im stall
in seiner verzweiflung holt danken
seinen nachbarn den farmer kennen zu
liefern
[Musik]
nach dallas mal auf die beine
mal sehen ob es sie streckt es streckt
sich ist das ein gutes zeichen
ja das ist sehr gut
warte jetzt noch zwei stunden und
bringen dann die mutter herein
vielleicht hängt es ja tag danken
schöpft wieder etwas hoffen
[Musik]
ein paar stunden später kommt der moment
der wahrheit danken will das versuchen
trinkt das kalb jetzt bei der mutter
bringen
[Musik]
ich habe richtig super
das absolut super ja
ja
[Musik]
vor seiner rede
am nächsten morgen alles hat sich zum
guten gewendet
das kranke kalb ist wieder draußen und
kann nicht genug kriegen von der
muttermilch
20 so ursprünglich super bin ich froh
dass ich schon schiss kurzzeichen danke
ich herzlich zum zuge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der wüste dubais hat monika
mittlerweile angefangen zu arbeiten
[Musik]
sie bietet fußmassagen an ihre kundin
ist heute die dir in den christen
ebenfalls die frau eines emirates
piloten
ich werde dir die massage nicht erklären
genießen sie einfach es kann sein dass
du leichte schmerzen spürt sie sollten
aber nach wenigen sekunden wieder weg
gehen monica ist ausgebildete massage
therapeutin diese ausbildung eine sanfte
energetische fust ohne massage hat sie
nach dem tod ihrer mutter für sich
entdeckt und diese erfahrungen will sie
jetzt auch in dubai weiter gegen
nach dem tod von ihrer mutter dazu
einfach auf andere in dem alter gefragt
habe was die szene ist vom labor
fermilab auf jeden fall
und was ich mache und was das wirklich
wichtig ist im leben
und da ist das auch mit japan hat auf
der anderen auf die maus gestoßen
es war sehr sehr entspannend ich bin
zwar nicht eingeschlafen aber ich war
ganz weit weg
[Musik]
in venezuela sind claudia und theres
unterdessen mit der kleinen katze bei
der tierärztin angekommen
[Musik]
noch immer mehr haut die katze
herzzerreißend
[Musik]
der ton ist rau
bei youtube ebay
naja
[Musik]
schauen sie ihre nieren haben wohl nicht
mehr funktioniert besteht nicht
[Musik]
hier habt ihr die reise von stress nicht
geglaubt dass ich es kann eine richtige
sätze 2
ja
ja die kleine katze ist in beiden in der
kurzen zeit stark ans herz gewachsen
[Musik]
in kongo hat hansjörg enz einen neuen
schweizer freund gefunden
[Musik]
1 besucht camus schule auf der baustelle
seines neuen restaurants um gemeinsam
mit ihm zu musizieren
[Musik]
mobil
letzte
sondern geben
als mitarbeiter bekommen und wäre gern
gekommen wo bekomme ich finde es absolut
lästig wie bei den sehr wenig wenn ich
nichts wieder her college jahr und ich
bin zwar mit dem schweizer sehr
verbunden
telefonisch und verliebt sich aber
natürlich auch leicht wieder hier
produkte also wieder einmal 15
michael ballack
[Musik]
jacobi
egal
die wahl
berlin
[Musik]
das überließ
[Applaus]
wie geht das
wien gekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in alice springs in australien genießen
schmieds ihr neues haus einiges hat sich
geändert
der schmied hat seit kurzem eine neue
haarfarbe und die vierjährige am ihrer
geht in den australischen kindergarten
in die preschool sehr zur freude der
eltern
in der breeze cool hat sich amira blitz
schnell eingelebt und mittlerweile
spricht sie auch wie eine australierin
[Musik]
vom erster das ist erstmalig facebook
hat völlig wird akzeptiert wurden
das wasser könne und deshalb bestätigte
hartmut teams die hand ein berliner kam
dann weiß ich das problem hier und jetzt
und selber jeder türkei
dass sie noch mal für den ehc
ich habe mich schon auf das was könnte
das bedeuten dass sie noch sehr gut
nun kann sich auch diener einen job
suchen
nächste woche in der letzten folge von
auf und davon
abenteuerliche erlebnis war tonis
gewesen das freizeitparadies dubai
ärger in venezuela das traumhaus audi
und er ist bald fertig doch die probleme
bleiben
[Musik]
die verzweiflung bei banken gar nur in
kanada das heu für seine kälber versinkt
im wasser
[Musik]
es ist einfach verlorenes geld wurde
rollenwechsel in australien diener
arbeitet und kate wird zum hausmann
[Musik]
entwicklungshilfe im kongo und ergänzt
für dorf eine neue schule
[Musik]